اكدوا وانا اكد لم تكن خيانه في الصفوف في
القيادات الاولى ولا القيادات الصف الثاني
على الاطلاق القاده العراقيين قاده كلهم
ابناء عشائر سواء من الشمال او الجنوب او
الوسط او المناطق الغربيه وعندهم يقاتلون
بعقيده عسكريه عراقيه مبنيه على مبدا
والعراق ابتدى عليه فلا اكد لا خيانه لا
في الصف الاول القياده العسكريه ولا في
الصف الثاني وما حصل هو تسريب لبعض يعني
الجنود
والقوه دائما يعني تبنى على يعني الجنود
صعودا بس كيف فسر لك صدام حسين سقوط
النظام بهذه السرعه
ودخول يعني احتمال الاحتلال بسرعه عدم
تكافؤ القوه يعني القوات العراقيه كانت
تقاتل بدون غطاء جوي
لسمتي ولا حربي
فرق شاسع جدا بين سلاح الامريكي والسلاح
العراقي المتهالك العراق محاصر ايضا منذ
1990 يعني 13 سنه محاصر فامر طبيعي ودقات
القوه وعظمى معها 40 دوله يعني اكيد
الموضوع مختلف تماما هذه الاسباب التي
قالها لك والسبب الاخر استخدام اميركا
للسلاح
النووي التكتيكي
في بغداد ولد صدمه يعني عندما الجندي
العراقي يشوف الدبابه تنصهر امامه وتتحول
الى سائل
وهول الضربه يعني ولد يعني الى يعني
تداعياته هل تاكدت دكتور خليل من الرئيس
العراقي الاسبق بخصوص المعركه التي
تحدثت معلومات انه قتل فيها
الفاع عنصر من القوات الامريكيه ولكن هناك
معلومات تقول ان القوات الامريكيه غطت على
هذا الموضوع وان الرئيس العراقي الاسبق
كان مشاركا في هذه العمليات نعم اخبرني
مشاركه فعاله من قبل في هذه المعركه معركه
المطار
واشترك ايضا هو طبعا سلاح الارض بالسفن
واكد في احد المرات
كان يعني
اثناء زيارتي له
قبل الجلوس كنا واقفين انا الرئيس الله
يرحمه
والجنرال
الامريكي واليام ستيل فصار حديث يعني
سالني كيف الوضع قلت له يعني الامريكان
سلموا العراق الايران فكان عصبي وكان يحكي
جنرال قال له اتحداكم تعلنوا عن الشعب
الامريكي وللعالم انت تعلنه عن خسائركم
اللي بلغت اكثر من 2000 جندي ماريز من
خيره القوات قتلت من القوات العراقيه خلال
معركه المطار خلال معركه المطار وطبعا ما
جاوبوا هذا القائد بقى ساكت وبعدين طلع
اين كان صدام حسين ليله الغزو
كان في بغداد
ولكن كان يعني ترك القصر طبعا خارج القصر
هو كان في المزرعه وعندما يعني قصفت
المزرعه قبل قصفها
بدقائق خرج منها
اين كان عند سقوط بغداد
يوم عشره
انتقل من شارع المطار الى المنصور الى
ثوره وطلع في مدينه الثوره او مدينه الصدر
في منازل عراقيين مواطنين
وبعدها انتقل الى الاعظميه وهناك
الثقب المقاتلين العرب
التقى بالاهل الاعظميه واهل العظميه
معروفين ببطنيتهم
يعني في تلك الفتره ضربت علي
الاحاديه مال احد المدرعات الامريكيه ضربت
فانصاب بشضيه قال الاصابه كانت طفيفه
بعدها
انتقل الى منطقه خارج بغداد
وطلب من مرافقي التفرق وهو نزل بزورق وعبر
على الضفه الثانيه واجا
محافظه الانبار الى بيت عائله الخربيط
وبعد ذلك
المفروض ان يبدا بالتخفي بعد ذلك
بعد ان القصف طلع الى منطقه هيت
ومن منطقه هيت انتقل الى محافظه صلاح
الدين وبدا من هناك يقود فصائل المقاومه